[Musique]
cette classe de cm1 pratique la radio
depuis une semaine à l'occasion de la
semaine de la presse et de notre venue à
l'école élémentaire and turgot à
sartrouville cette vingtaine d'élèves
avaient préparé une émission sur le
métier de journaliste et nous a posé des
questions comment on est rendus en
[Musique]
colère cette année ce sont trois classes
de cm1 qui participent au projet radio
dans un premier temps on a fait de
l'interprétation de poésie pour les
familiariser avec toute la technique et
puis apprendre à parler au micro et là
maintenant on rentre vraiment dans
l'enseignement aux médias en menant des
pieds reportage comment fonctionne une
rédaction qu'est ce qu'un reportage ou
comment se construit un journal autant
de sujets développés avec trois classes
à écoute les élèves ont appris beaucoup
comment faisait la radio comment et
effet la radio télévisée c'est à dire à
la télé comment là on la prépare est
combien de temps devait durer une
chronique
combien de temps dure et la rédaction
j'ai appris c'est quoi tes marines et
des crues et faciliterait la caméra
c'était vraiment découvrir à inside le
métier de journaliste les différents
rôles que ce soit chroniqueur au
reporter vraiment vivre le quotidien des
journalistes
les trois minutes de reportage c'est un
processus d'une journée avec
effectivement le rôle du chef de
rédaction le monteur donc tout ce qu'on
ne voit pas à l'écran qui est ô combien
important il était en tout cas important
pour nous de faire partager à ses élèves
de neuf ans notre métier et de leur
donner envie pourquoi pas de devenir à
leur tour journaliste